etienne et polis agriculteurs ils
cultivent 160 hectares de différentes
céréales
l'hiver a été pluvieux mais les
températures de ces derniers jours
rendent ces terres particulièrement
sèche en ce début de printemps
normalement les soldes devraient être
encore bien alimenté bons en surface
c'est desséché en dessous c'est encore
relativement humide
le problème c'est si ça continue à se
dessécher c'est à dire si on n'a pas de
pluies régulières d'ici d'ici l'été
les cultures pourraient être en
difficulté et si un déficit en nous à ce
moment là et bien évidemment il y aura
moins de récolte les grains sont plus
petits voire y aura pas de récolte du
tout l'absence de récolte la hantise
chez les agriculteurs les épisodes
climatiques de plus en plus violents et
les variations de température observée
ces derniers jours sont aussi peu
apprécié par le bétail
quand on passe de
2 - 1 - 1 - 2 à 20 degrés derrière c'est
s'est passé pas terrible et puis surtout
les animaux qui sont en grande partie de
leur vie dehors au près ils subissent
cette amplitude thermique puis après il
ya surtout les grandes chaleurs l'été 40
degrés même avec de longs c'est
compliqué pour les animaux des
variations de température difficile à
gérer
depuis cent quarante trois ans météo
france enregistre des données
météorologiques à bourges une hausse de
1,7 degré a été constatée surtout ces
quarante dernières années l'augmentation
de ces températures se traduira
forcément par des risques accrus de
périodes de canicule estivale en 2020
l'été n'a pas été excessivement chaud
pour autant 2020 en moyenne sur l'année
a été l'année la plus chaude enregistrée
à bourges réduire les gaz à effet de
serre et limiter la pollution
industrielle et modifier les transports
pour et éviter ou au moins réduire le
réchauffement climatique
un vaste sujet dans lequel gouvernements
et collectivités locales ont leur rôle à
jouer dans les années à venir